hi I'm Cano and this is my recipe for
chocolate filled banana muffins in this
video I kicked it off with a hack to
making your bananas baking ready by
putting them in the oven
it really helps soften it up and get it
that nice like puree texture if they're
kind of baked off and those sugars can
really help soften up the banana now I
chose to use a banana because of the
popularity of the fruit bananas are the
most widely grown and eaten fruit in the
world so I know that more people are
gonna have access this ingredient
because they are just so available which
is a big part of our process here at ICI
is thinking not only about what is great
and delicious but also what do people
have access to and what's like maybe
already on your kitchen counter that you
want to just like throw into a recipe
this style of muffin is actually
inspired by a French pastry where excuse
my french
they'll probably butcher the
pronunciation but it's tequila which is
like tiger and I think it's because by
hiding the chocolate sprinkles it kind
of looks like it has tiger stripes now
that pastry is actually a tea cake where
it's like a little Pinot
that has the chocolate sprinkles and
it's sometimes filled with chocolate
ganache and I thought it was such a cool
pastry that I'd never actually seen
around in America and has often the same
stylistic characteristics and
transferring it into a muffin which
people are probably more likely to be
familiar with and want to make at home
so just like the Seger I use the
chocolate sprinkles just together that
cool stripe feeling so dessert and then
once the muffins came out the oven I use
just the back of a wooden spoon to
create a little hole and fill that with
chocolate ganache so kind of like
elevated the breakfast muffin to like a
next level
don't know how to call it but they're
good matters
so there's a joke in TC about how much I
think with bananas considering they are
far from my favorite fruit now I'm not a
complete banana hater I just don't like
them once they are ripen but I keep my
personal friends of society because I
know literally planet Earth loves
bananas more than anything and there's
actually a lot of wastes tied to bananas
because once they reach a certain point
most people think that they're inedible
and want to toss them in the trash so my
first tasty video I ever did was
actually four different ways a bakery
bright bananas literally millions of
bananas are tossed out every day because
people think that they're too ripe and
they don't like how they look and funny
enough the ripe bananas are the ones you
want to bake with so if you have ripen
in is in your house and you're like oh I
don't want to eat that I feel you I
understand
put it in the freezer think of it later
and you can make some muffins hashtag
[Laughter]
[Music]